die fahrgäste sind wieder da und sie
kommen in scharen
volle züge und bahnsteige nicht nur dann
neun euro ticket im regionalverkehr
sondern auch in der weißen flotte der
fernzüge trotz masten pflicht in den
waggons andrang wie vor der pandemie für
dieses jahr hatte der staatskonzern
deutsche bahn sich vorgenommen nach zwei
jahren corona endlich wieder geld zu
verdienen auf erdrückende
34,5 milliarden euro waren die schulden
zuletzt gestiegen es mangelt an
effizienz sagen kritiker die bahn hat in
den letzten jahren eben sehr viele bahn
ferne geschäfte dazu gekauft mit denen
man eben weitgehend kein geld verdient
sondern die geld kosten das ist das eine
problem das zweite problem ist dass die
bahn ihre bürokratie sehr stark
aufgebläht hat was zum einen prozesse
langsamer macht aber eben auch kosten
verursacht hinzu kommt alle drei wochen
wird ein neuer ic 4 ausgeliefert und
muss dann auch bezahlt werden so steigt
zwar das platzangebot doch die neue
schnellzüge starten in ein bahnsystem im
desolate im zustand die pünktlichkeit im
fernverkehr ist mit 58 prozent auf einen
tiefstand gesunken was jeder zweite zug
erreicht sein ziel mit mehr als sechs
minuten deutlich verspätet hauptgrund
noch nie wurde so viel am schienennetz
gebaut verschlissene fahrwege veraltete
technik was über jahre vernachlässigt
wurde soll jetzt in einem kraftakt fit
für doppelt so viele fahrgäste ab 2030
werden zeitweise auf über 850 baustellen
pro tag geplant von der db netz sparte
deren bau koordinierung offenbar
mitverantwortlich für verspätungen ist
die deutsche bahn muss auf jeden fall
baustellenmanagement in griff kriegen
nicht mehr für jede maßnahme eine
einzelne sperrungen wir haben viel zu
viel streckensperrungen die zu einer
drastischen reduzierung der kapazität
und zu vielen verspätungen führt
probleme die jetzt die kundschaft
ausbaden muss wer sich für die bahn als
verkehrsmittel entscheidet muss aktuell
mit verspätungen verpassten anschlüssen
rechnen und wird damit oft allein
gelassen sagt der fahrgast
es muss sehr viel mehr und sehr viel
besser informiert werden und man muss
vor allen dingen auch die dinge die in
der zukunft passieren könnten durchaus
mit einplanen und sagen liebe leute
fahrt vorsichtshalber dann lieber so das
klappt auf alle fälle und genau das
fehlt unpünktliche züge baustellenchaos
rekordschulden es läuft nicht rund bei
der db und das obwohl sie gerade jetzt
so stark nachgefragt ist wie schon lange
nicht mehr
gibt noch einiges zu besprechen carl
waßmuth vom fahrgastverband bahn für
alle ist bei uns im moma café herzlich
willkommen heute morgen können wir
morgen
beziehen halbjahresbilanz wie sieht ihre
bilanz aus daumen hoch oder daumen
runter ja wir haben sozusagen licht und
schatten die bahn
zu kritisieren das ist jetzt kein
kunststück das kann jeder man kann sagen
alles ist schlecht und es ist wirklich
sehr viel sehr schlecht aber diese
bahnen die wir haben kann trotzdem noch
schlechter werden von daher ist die
bilanz so wir haben eine grundstruktur
die noch funktionieren könnte wenn man
die bahnen steuern würde und dass man
die bahn steuern kann das hat
interessanterweise der neue
verkehrsminister gezeigt so quasi mit
einem fingerschnippen hatte mit dem
neuen euro ticket gesteuert und jetzt
sind alle sehr aufgeregt denn 20 jahre
lang haben alle behauptet man könnte die
bahn nicht steuern sie kritisieren ja
auch dass die bahn das schienennetz
nicht bilanziert was meinen sie genau
damit und was warum ist das so
entscheidend ja wir haben also heute
bilanzpressekonferenz der bahn der db ag
und wir haben diese bilanz
pressekonferenzen andauernd halbjahres
und jahresbilanzen und seit 1994 werden
diese bilanzen gezogen aber das sind
sehr zweifelhafte veranstaltungen man
muss nämlich wissen dass das netz das
schienennetz das netto weit über 100
milliarden euro wert ist nie bilanziert
wurde das heißt also da wird etwas
gerechnet und der größte kostenfaktor
und das wichtigste elementarste kommt
darin gar nicht vor das heißt das ist
betriebswirtschaftliche rechnung und
keine volkswirtschaftliche aber wir
haben jetzt gemerkt die bahn ist eine
volkswirtschaftliche einrichtung der
daseinsvorsorge und wir brauchen sie für
den
für die auf gegen den klimawandel
sozusagen vorzugehen um die
verkehrswende zu bekommen und die bahn
bilanziert das nicht und sie macht keine
abschreibungen und sie spart kosten
indem sie am netz spart und deswegen ist
es so kaputt und die züge sind voller
denn je sie haben das neun euro ticket
er schon angesprochen viele unserer
zuschauer hier zuschauerinnen sind
vielleicht auch mit der bahn angereist
und wir haben bei dunja jemanden der
auch so seine erfahrung gemacht hat wir
haben ja gerade gehört die bahn sei
steuerbar was die preisstruktur
anbelangt mag das stimmen wie wir gerade
sehen aber was die pünktlichkeit
anbelangt da scheint sie und steuerbar
zu sein passt alles bei mir schon morgen
aus grünheide okay das heißt sie sind
heute auch mit der bahn gekommen ja und
die hatte nur eine minute verspätung
wenn sie das schon so sagen das heißt
ihre er erfahrungswelt liegt aber sonst
wobei fünf bis zehn minuten oder öfter
auch mal für stürme oder eine halbe
stelle das heißt sie verpassen
grundsätzlich ihre anschlussbusse und da
muss man dann schon öfter eineinhalb
stunden auf den nächsten warten oder
halt auch mal eine stunde nach hause
laufen und sie sind auf die bahn
angewiesen weil ich täglich zur schule
muss und dann kommen sie permanent zu
spät zur schule nicht permanent aber
mindestens einmal die woche
okay das natürlich was eine schöne aber
nur ausreden hier hat auch noch
wahrheitsgehalt vielen dank da geschehen
ist ja auch eine erfahrung von vielen
wahrscheinlich das liegt nicht nur aber
auch am neuen euro ticket zum beispiel
immer mehr menschen jetzt in diesen drei
monaten fahren mit diesem ticket die
züge sind voll finden sie denn dass das
noch ein euro ticket jetzt eine gute
idee war oder eher nicht dass da ein
euro ticket war eine sehr gute idee und
das sollte auch unbedingt fortgesetzt
werden das hat mehrere dinge gezeigt zum
einen hat es gezeigt dass man steuern
kann das hat gezeigt dass wir die ganze
zeit in einer extremen kleinstaaterei
gelebt haben jetzt kann man auf einmal
deutschlandweit mit einem ticket fahren
also das lieben die menschen und zu
recht man muss nicht mehr in diesem
verkehrsverbund und mit diesem rabatt
und da ist die grenze es hat aber auch
die probleme gezeigt wir haben eine bahn
die extrem abgebaut hat 17 prozent
schienennetz 40 weichen
160.000 vollzeitbeschäftigte wurden
sozusagen abgebaut die stellen sind
verloren gegangen und das fehlt uns
jetzt haben wir die vollen züge die
leute machen endlich das was sie sollen
die fahren mit einem ökologischen
verkehrsmittel aber das ist natürlich
voll und die beschäftigten dort kommen
an ihren ganzen frage ist ja was tun sie
haben jetzt viel von steuern gesprochen
also in welche richtung sollte die
bundesregierung sollte der
bundesverkehrsminister die deutsche bahn
steuer der sollte insofern student indem
er dem
sag ich mal eigenen unternehmen das
gehört uns hat die deutsche bahn ist zu
100 prozent in bundeseigentum sagt toll
gemacht ihr habt gezeigt wir können
sozusagen ein ticket einführen und jetzt
brauchen wir noch die leute die wagen
und die sage ich mal die infrastruktur
die diese vielen leute dann dauerhaft da
transportieren kann und wir brauchen
vielleicht auch noch einen neuen
interregio denn das ist das was fehlt
zwischen regionalverkehr und fernverkehr
die leute fahren einem seltenen 500
kilometer er so zwischen 50 und 150 und
dafür gibt es gar kein zug system und
spätestens am ende des jahres ziehen wir
wieder bilanz carl waßmuth war das vom
fahrgastverband bahn für alle herzlichen
dank ich danke ihnen
[Applaus]